PROFESSOR: We're going
to look at the most
fundamental of all mathematical
data types, namely sets,
and let's begin with
the definitions.
So informally, a
set is a collection
of mathematical
objects, and the idea
is that you treat the collection
of objects as one new object.
And that's a working definition.
But of course, it might
help a little bit,
but it's a circular definition.
This is not math yet
because I haven't defined
what a collection
is, and a collection
is no clearer or easier
to define than a set is.
So let's try to work
up the idea of sets
by looking at some examples.
So we've already talked
about some familiar ones.
There's the real
numbers for which
we had this symbol
R in a special font,
and the complex numbers
C, and the integers
Z. And we might have
mentioned, and you
might have seen already, the
idea of the empty set for which
we use this symbol that
looks like a zero with a line
through it.
Let's look at an example
to pin things down.
Let's look at this
set of four things.
Namely, it's got two numbers,
pi/2 and 7, a character
string in quotes, "Albert R,"
and the Boolean value true.
So those are the four
different things in it.
They're of mixed type.
And you might not like to
have a mixed type like this
in a programming language.
But mathematicians don't worry
about such things very much,
rarely.
Anyway, the first
observation is that the order
in which these elements
are listed doesn't matter.
This set-- the braces
indicates that it's
the set of these
things-- is the same if I
listed T first, then the string,
and the two numbers last.
There is no notion
of order in a set.
Now, to a computer scientist
this is a little unnatural.
The most natural
thing to be would
be to define a
sequence of things,
like the sequence that
began with 7, then
had the character string,
then had the number,
then had the Boolean.
And you could get by with
working with lists of things
as long as they're finite.
But they very quickly
get out of hand
when you have to talk
about, say, a set of lists.
Then it's not clear how to
make a list out of those,
and you wind up
making sets again.
So sets, in fact, are an
unavoidable kind of idea.
So another basic
thing to understand
about the notion of a
set is that an element
is either in a set
or not in a set.
So if I write down
7, pi/2, 7, this
is the same description
of the same set 7, pi/2.
I'm just telling you the
same thing twice here.
That 7 is in the set, and
the 7 is in the set again.
So no notion of being in
the set more than once.
Now, sometimes,
technically you want
to add a notion of
so-called multisets
in which elements
can be in a set
a certain number of times,
an integer number of times.
But there's no
real need for that.
It's a secondary idea.
And from our point of view,
you're in or out of a set.
If you repeat elements, it's the
same as mentioning them once.
So the most fundamental feature
of a set is what's in it.
And for that, there's
a special notation.
So we'll say that x is a
member of A, where A is a set,
and use this epsilon symbol
to indicate membership.
It's read x is a member
of A. So for example, pi/2
is a member of that set that we
saw before that had pi/2 in it.
14/2 is also a member of
that set because 14/2 is just
another description of 7.
When I write 7 here, I
don't mean the character 7.
I mean the number 7.
And so 14/2 is the description
of the same number.
It's in that set.
On the other hand,
pi/3 is a number
that's simply not in that set.
So I'm using the epsilon with
a vertical bar through it,
or some kind of a line through
it, to mean not a member of.
Membership is so basic that
there's a lot of different ways
to say it.
Besides using the membership
symbol x is a member of A,
you can sometimes say
x is an element of A,
or x is in A, as well
as x is a member of A.
They're all synonyms.
So for example, 7 is a
member of the integers.
Z is our symbol
for the integers.
2/3 is not a member
of the integers
because it's a fraction
that's not an integer.
And on the other hand,
the set Z of integers
itself is a member of this
three-element set consisting
of the truth value T,
the set of all integers,
and the element 7.
So here's an example where a
set can contain sets, quite
big ones even, and that's fine.
That's not any problem
mathematically.
Related to membership is another
fundamental notion of subset.
So A is a subset of
B, it's pronounced.
So that horizontal U
with a line under it
is meant to resemble a less
than or equal to symbol.
So you can think of it as being
A is less than or equal to B.
But don't overload the symbols.
Less than or equal to is used
on numbers and other things
that we know how to order.
And this is a relation that's
only allowed between sets.
So A is a subset of B-- A
synonym is that A is contained
in B-- simply means
that every element of A
is also an element
of B. If I wrote
that out in predicate
logic notation
as a predicate formula, I'd say
for every x, x is in A implies
x is in B. If it's in A, then
it's in B. Everything in A
is in B.
So some examples of
the subset relation
are that the integers are
a kind of-- an integer
is a special case
of a real number.
So the set of integers is a
subset of the real numbers.
A real number is a special
case of a complex number,
so the real numbers are a
subset of the complex numbers.
And here's a concrete
example, where
I have a set of three
things, 5, 7, and 3,
and this is the set with
just the element 3 in it.
Now, we sometimes are
sloppy about distinguishing
the element 3 from the set
that's consisting of just 3
as its only element.
But in fact, it's a pretty
important distinction
to keep track of.
In this case, 3 is not a subset
of this set on the right.
But the set consisting of 3 is
a subset of the set on the right
because, after all, the only
member of this set is 3,
and that is a
member of this set.
A consequence of this general
definition is that every set is
a subset of itself because
everything in A is in A .
That's not really
very interesting.
Another important
general observation
is that the empty set is
a subset of everything.
The empty set is a
subset of every set.
Let's look at why that
is in more detail.
So the claim is that the empty
set is a subset of everything.
Let B be any old set,
then the empty set
is a subset of B. What exactly
does that mean according
to the definition of subset?
Well, it says that everything
that's in the empty set,
if it's in the
empty set, then it
implies that it's in
B. For every element,
if it's in the empty
set, then it's in B.
Well, what do we
know about this?
The assertion that x is
in the empty set is false.
No matter what x is, there's
nothing in the empty set.
And now I have an
implication that
implies where the left-hand
side, the hypothesis, is false.
That means that the whole
implication is true,
and it doesn't
depend on what B is.
I'm not even going
to look at B. I
can see that x is in
empty set is false,
so the whole
implication is true.
And so what I'm saying
is that for every x,
something that's
true has to be true.
Well, it is.
And that's why the empty
set is a subset of B
satisfies this definition
in a formal way.
And this is an example
of why that convention
that false implies anything
is convenient and is made
use here.
So when you're defining
sets, if they're small,
you can just list
the elements, as we
did with that set with 7
and pi/2 and "Albert R."
Sometimes we can even
describe infinite sets
as some kind of a list.
Like I might describe the
set of integers as saying,
well, it's 0, 1, minus
1, 2, minus 2, and so on,
and you would understand that.
But in general,
if I'm describing
a set that is not
so easy to list,
say the real numbers,
then what I'm going to do
is define a set by a defining
property of in the set.
So I'm interested in a
property P of elements,
and I'm going to look
at the set of elements
x that are in some set A
such that P of x is true,
and that's the notation we use.
So this would be read as the
set of x in A such that P of x
holds, that x has property P.
So notice this vertical bar is
read as "such that."
It's just a mathematical
abbreviation.
This is those elements in A
that have property P that P of x
holds for, and that defines
a set of those elements.
Let's look at a simple example.
The set E of even integers is
simply the set of numbers n
that are integers
such that n is even.
So in this case, the property
P of n means that n is even.
One last concept is the
concept of the power set.
So the power set of a set A
is all of the subsets of A.
So we could define
it using set notation
as it's the set of
B such that B is
a subset of A. An
example would be--
let's take the power set
of the two Boolean values
true and false.
So the power set
of true and false,
of that set consisting
of two elements,
is-- well, what are
some of its subsets?
The set consisting of just true
is a subset of true, false.
So is the set
consisting of false,
and so is the whole thing.
It's a subset of itself.
And one final element,
the empty set,
is a subset of the set of
Boolean values true and false.
So the power set of
this two-element set
is a set that has four things
in it-- two elements of size 1,
one element of size 2,
one element of size 0.
And that's going to be
a general phenomenon
that we'll examine more later.
How big is the
power set of a set?
The even numbers, E that we just
defined on the previous slide,
is a member of the power
set of Z because it's
a subset of integers.
Even integers are a
special case of integers.
And the integers are a
member of the power set of R.
That's just a synonym
for saying that integers
are a subset of reals.
Every integer is a
real, so the integers
are a subset of
reals, which means
they're a member of
the power set of reals.
So the general property
is that a set B
is a member of the power
set of A if and only
if B is a subset of A.
That was the defining
condition for power set.
And that's a fact to remember,
and it may potentially
confuse you.
But it's a good
exercise in keeping
track of the difference
between is a member of
and is a subset of.